what's up guys cherry here with another
movie review little delayed reaction
it's not a first impression anymore cuz
I saw this movie like last week anyhow
let's get right to it
I saw Nightcrawler Nightcrawler is a new
film starring Jake Gyllenhaal right off
the bat I gotta say I'm really happy
that Jake Gyllenhaal has become an actor
Hey I'm sorry that was me uh Jake
Gyllenhaal was always a guy I never
really thought that much about and
recently he's has been blowing me away
like prisoner is his performance and
prisoners [ __ ] the Sun and recently
he's been blowing me away I mean his
performance in prisoners is one of my
favorite performances in recent memory I
don't know how long but uh but he really
did blow me away in that movie and he's
continuing that streak here so I'm
Nightcrawler is a movie written and
directed by a guy named Dan Gilroy he's
been working as a writer in Hollywood
for a while and you actually might
recognize his brothers name Tony Gilroy
Tony Gilroy wrote a number of the Bourne
movies he wrote I believe Michael
Clayton duplicity he's been kicking
around I actually quite like Tony Gilroy
as a writer so this is his brother Dan
his tenth I believe writing project and
his first as a director um so how does
it check out well let's get into it
Nightcrawler is a very strange film in a
lot of ways and all the ways I kind of
like you know generally this is a movie
about this slimy opportunist named Lou
bloom Louis bloom is his name and we
sort of happened upon him at the
beginning of this film sort of looking
for gainful employment and he sort of
stumbles his way into the field of night
crawling as one of the characters refers
to it as which is basically getting a
camera showing up at crime scenes and
recording you know footage of victims or
or wreckage or whatever and then selling
that footage to local news stations for
them to
you know put on their headline stories
so this is a really twisted movie in a
lot of very interesting ways and to me
this almost played like a black comedy
like a really really dark comedy because
so much of it is very absurd in the way
Lou bloom manages to get around because
this guy and again I gotta hand it to
Jake Gyllenhaal he is incredible in this
movie he really embodies this guy and
you forget about Jake Gyllenhaal really
I mean which I guess is the great mark
of any character actor which is sort of
what he's becoming now it seems like
he's really gaunt and he's got these bug
eyes and he has this he's very
persuasive and he's very sort of you get
this sense of this is one of those guys
who spent a lot of time studying you
know various ways of influencing people
and business and he would do really well
in network marketing and I'll imagine
like this is the kind of guy who knows
all the various quotes and sayings and
philosophies of how to work your way up
and how to influence people I'm going to
say the right things to get people to do
what you want them to do so he's this
skeevy opportunist manipulator guy and
he's just fantastic he's is he's so
compelling to watch and he's so kind of
upsetting in in in in a very sly and
interesting way he also doesn't blink
very much which it's just friggin creepy
so yeah Jake Gyllenhaal is definitely a
big standout in this movie and there's a
lot of a lot of good performances in it
too I mean I quite liked Rene Russo I
really liked Bill Paxton who shows up as
a supporting character who had forgotten
completely that he was in it up until he
showed up on screen so that was a nice
surprise and risa met is also in this
movie he's an actor who's been in some
things recently he looked familiar to me
when I saw it I didn't quite fully know
where I recognized him from but he sort
of plays this this slacker a guy who
joins Jake Gyllenhaal's organization so
too
and he's also really good and their
inner play off each other is great um so
this is a movie that really does sort of
stand on its performances and while it
does certainly have a plot that goes
somewhere it is kind of a character
study in a lot of ways a very sick and
twisted one at that you're sort of
watching this guy do whatever he can to
just keep gaining power and influence
and and and whatnot and it's a really
compelling twisted dark movie and it and
I gotta hand it to them because they
balance a lot of tones really well in
various strange ways you know I was I
was partly I was laughing a lot during
this movie not because I thought it was
silly or or or because it's a comedy so
to speak but there are so many sort of
sly and ridiculous things that this guy
gets away with and the things that this
guy says to people and it's it's funny
because we understand him with the
people around him don't necessarily so
um there's a lot of really dark humor
here and then sometimes it's
legitimately unsettling and it does get
under your skin especially in some of
these these crime scene sequences that
really clue you into just how dark and
depraved Lewis Bloom is you know at his
core and there's certain moments as well
where it gets into that territory where
you're like this isn't a horror movie
but it's a horror movie you know there
are some moments that are really tense
and suspenseful and you know unsettling
so I really got to hand it to them for
the tone I also really like the way it
was shot it's it's it's captured really
well and it's captured in a in a very
interesting and uncomfortable way and in
a way that sort of supports the the
voyeuristic and the intrusive quality of
the work that Lou bloom is doing here so
that's a that's that's a good forming
thing and I also liked a lot of the
music there are some music choices that
are a little peculiar because the the
music almost seems to operate in this
ironic way half the time where you are
sort of watching these guys he accrues
success and in a normal movie like in a
movie about an actual good
I you know that movie would that music
would be fitting
it's just that louis loom is not a good
guy and his rise to success is perhaps
not a good thing I had the greater
scheme of living but uh so there are
some ironic music choices there although
they did work for me once I sort of at
least arrived at that conclusion I guess
you would say because they added another
layer to that to that humor it supports
his emotion even if we the audience
aren't so he's sitting there there's one
scene where he's sitting there in the
news station after they've just you know
bought some particularly great piece of
footage and the music swells as he sits
there and sort of revels in his you know
achievement and the music supports that
even though we're sitting here going
like oh no it does also sort of raise
questions and touch upon the idea of
desensitization to violent images in our
society and how far broadcast news is
going into shock you know to grab
ratings and stuff and the business
behind journalism and I'm not again an
expert but I do know some people of
studying journalism and that's a lot of
what the deeper implications of this
movie are about our ethics in journalism
in the news and crime reporting and
whatnot and how intrusive a lot of this
stuff is it does sort of pick up and
play with that disconnect from humanity
you know you're watching these people
pour over these videos from crime scenes
of people bleeding or or wounds being
patched up by EMTs and stuff like that
and they're sitting there like all this
great footage and you're like but it's
people and no um so it is relevant in
that way because you know news
especially now
has become sort of a dubious platform
because news now is subject to money and
ratings and shock and we gotta bring
people to our station versus another
station so it does play with and touch
on those ideas and they are relevant
today you know because you turn on the
news and it's sort of increasingly
upsetting nowadays so that's you know as
sort of interesting facet about this
movie as much as it is a character study
it's also sort of a portrait of society
that way so I think it is a really
interesting piece on those levels and I
really liked what they did here it's
it's dark and it's it's kind of mean and
nasty in certain ways but it finds a way
to make you really enjoy watching very
not likable people so I gotta give them
credit for that and I really like this
movie a lot so uh yeah Nightcrawler
definitely go check it out you know it
might not be everyone's cup of tea but
it's certainly the kind of thing that
appeals to me and they did a great job
for my money I'm really excited to go
see it again as twisted as that sounds
so um yeah let me know your thoughts if
you saw Nightcrawler what did you think
about it and you know let's talk about
Jake Gyllenhaal what's your what's your
favorite Jake Gyllenhaal movie in recent
memory because you know he's kind of him
and Matthew McConaughey man they're
they've come out of the stint of doing
these sort of you know Hollywood
romantic comedies and various things
like that and now they're starting to
take on really interesting and really we
need rules now and I'm really excited to
see that so so what have you what have
you seen of Jake Gyllenhaal's recent
work or or it may be even his older work
that you really liked let's talk about
that so yeah like subscribe comment all
that be kind to your compatriots in the
comments box let's keep it constructive
and until next time Cheers
you